and I feel like these things like like
we've sort of touched on a few times in
this conversation is like these things
that uh demonized these days in any way
that men want to get better it's shamed
and it's disappointing to see because
there are a lot of young guys out there
who are totally and utterly lost in the
world and I have them come and reach out
to me and I'm like man I'm 27. I'm I'm
really figuring out like go and
read Rich's book like to be honest I I
got my brother onto your book as well
and he was just like I can't believe
because my brother's a bit more
naturally sort of alpha my older brother
and he was like I can't believe there
are other people who think like me but
for me it was a bit more like it was a
it was an unplugging for me because I'm
probably a little bit more I had to I
had to go through that phase and go
through that like loss of the safe world
theory so there are a lot of young guys
out there who are coming even to me into
guys like yourself and the internet and
seeking advice because obviously their
fathers are too much of a to give
them proper for advice about how to be a
man or they don't have fathers or
they've just been so indoctrinated by
feminism and by Hollywood and by woke
culture so in terms of young guys and
I'm talking like anywhere from 15 to 25
30 even
um where do they start
well I mean a good start is by reading
my book it's kind of a a pathway to
unplugging you know generally speaking
um but it like it like it boils down to
this you know the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
again expecting a different result and
that's essentially what I had done you
know a lot of my life is I had done what
they had they in quotations had had told
me to do culture Hollywood religion
family Society government school all
that stuff I listen to what they said
and I believed it and then I did what
they said to do and some of it works
some of it doesn't work right like a lot
of the stuff with attraction and keeping
women around that that you hear your
entire life like just be a nice guy you
know sort of thing that doesn't
work you'll get walked on by women
um walked all over sorry you know by
women
um leading a relationship is something
that men need to do right and you know
we've been told by Society culture and
toxic feminism and all this stuff that
you know men and women are equal and
um you know one of the things that I
talk about often when people call in on
my podcast shows is they'll often say
some you know like the word partner and
that word irritates me to no end because
I don't know it like are you a partner
in a law firm are you in a lesbian
relationship same-sex I can't tell why
can't we use the conventional words that
we've always used like husband wife
boyfriend girlfriend you know like
whatever that happens to be right but
you know we we tend to try to like
neuter and neutralize language
and I think the first step in unplugging
is
um seeing all the out there and
then you know the other step obviously
that that comes with it in parallel is
seeing your own and once you
can see
you know the lies versus the truth then
Things become more clear I mean one of
the things that a lot of guys say to me
once they sort of kind of go go through
the unplugging processes they're like
you know I can't listen to music the
same way that I used to because it's all
you know it's all trying to plug me back
into like the Matrix or whatever it is
that you want to call it's trying to
plug me back into the lies right oh Pine
for her cry for her put her up on a
pedestal write her poems and love
stories and all this kind of and
it's like yeah that might work on some
women some of the time for a short
period of time but that's not what keeps
women around over a long-term basis
that's not what keeps them obsessed with
you I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out